Yeah.
Can you share with us your reading habits?
Max says,
I'm sorry I'm skipping over some questions but I have to answer some easier ones
because I'm out of the capacity to answer difficult ones.
Okay.
I'll answer this one instead.
If you could talk to Donald Trump for a day,
what would you try to say or convinced them about?
I don't think I would try to convince them about things.
I don't actually try to convince people about things.
I don't think I tried to ask them.
I'd ask him a whole bunch of questions.
I try to figure out how we thought cause I'm really curious about that.
I'd ask them all sorts of questions,
ask,
see if I could find out what he was up to.
I'd like to know what he's aiming at.
I'd like to know why he thinks he became president,
what he did right,
what he did wrong,
what,
what he dreads,
like what he would consider a catastrophic failure,
where he thinks his biggest weaknesses are,
what he'd like to leave as a,
as a legacy.
Um,
okay.
That would be fascinating.
But see,
I find generally speaking,
it's much more interesting to ask people questions,
especially people like that,
than ever to try to convince them of things.
Because the thing is,
I already know what I know,
but I have no idea what he knows or what he's like.
And so it'd be amazing to be able to talk to them.
And so I have a bit of that opportunity now in Canada because I've been speaking
to a lot of political figures in Canada.
I'm going to have that opportunity in Europe.
But a lot of,
a lot of what you want to do when you meet people is ask them questions because,
you know,
they'll tell you all sorts of things you don't know.
And,
um,
that's also an entry point to a really good conversation is to ask questions.
So that's what I would do.
I'd ask questions like mad until he chased me away.
So,
okay.